if you want the answer uh
yeah i could give the money back it is
within my power um
but i'm gonna look out for myself and
not do that i i you know i don't like
know what else to say that's just the
most honest answer
[Music]
yo yo what's up
what's up
hey man hey yeah i wanted to call
because uh
i know we've talked about cx coin before
and you said hey let let you know if
anything's suspicious
and uh things are looking mad suspicious
it looks like
the coin got rugged
you know anything about that
i mean yeah i mean not rugged but uh i
mean
well someone pulled all the liquidity
out that's a that's a rub right
that would be a rug yes uh but
there is still liquidity in there
what like a yeah i mean the majority got
ripped out right what
40k got left and 300k got ripped out or
something like that
yeah i mean
that is exactly what happened
right are you laughing i mean
is that funny
um i mean no
okay but
right so do you want to tell me what
happened or
yeah i mean it's uh
pretty simple
basically the coin was inactive for a
long time
the crypto market is crashing
and obviously i'm not gonna let three
hundred thousand dollars go to waste
and crumble into nothing if bnb goes to
50
so i took out what wasn't necessary in
the liquidity based on the trade volume
and i left
enough in there for people to buy or
sell or whatever they want to do
wait what do you mean go to waste like
that's how people get out right like
liquidity is how people get out if you
rip 300k out that's 300k that people
can't get out
right but there's 42k in the liquidity
right now so that is i mean that's
literally nothing
i mean there's not
much money invested into the coin at
this point
right but
you understand like you called this
thing a long-term project from the
get-go right you told everybody it
wasn't a scam you had these videos
where you said you were joking where you
said you'd scam people as soon as you
thought the money was going to be
basically taken away you were going to
rip it out from under everybody uh and
then you i asked you about it you said
it's a you were joking
it doesn't seem like a joke anymore it
seems like you scammed your fans
uh no not a not a scam um you don't
think we're drawing 300k is is a scam
like at the time the project needs it
the most
um i mean no i don't think so it's uh
there's no trade volume on the coin bro
it's inactive you know i didn't want to
do the coin anymore well the uh well
people were waiting for like you to do i
mean really deliver on the like you know
marketing that the marketing wallet
nobody knows what happened with that
um because you were promising to get
influencers on board people were
basically waiting to deliver i think it
was inactive because there wasn't a lot
of um
like i mean you basically hyped up this
coin you took a bunch of people's money
to invest
and then
you know i mean you're just like taking
the money as soon as the coin dies down
for a bit
uh well i'll put it this way so when i
release the coin
obviously i have i had good intentions
with it um there was a lot of [ __ ] that
happened when i released the coin you
know
twitter got banned all this different
stuff the coin dumped and obviously
everyone said it was scam and all this
stuff influencers aren't going to want
to work with that for one and for two it
already had so much bad
publicity and seo
that it just was uh it just wasn't gonna
work
with the visions that i had
right
so
at that case
your first impulse is to just grab for
the money that's still there
i mean
i wouldn't say that's my first impulse
but
well it's basically as soon as the
liquidity got unlocked that's what you
did right so
i mean what's the alternative
the alternative is at minimum people can
try to get their money back right
because that's that's not your money
that's people's investment who believed
in you and you said as a long-term
project you're going to be working on it
for years to come whatever
and then
you do the opposite i don't know how
this could like how you could not see
this as a total scam
this this was a scam you said something
it wasn't delivered and you took the
money
that's a scam you know
well i used the uh we made the platform
i used it
people weren't donating with it
um
i don't really know like like obviously
it just wasn't working out
so it's not a scam i tried
but it just didn't work out and it
already had so much bad publicity on it
that i just didn't want anything to do
with it anymore the coin was a fork of
another coin
the integration got hacked day one i
mean the platform really didn't work
and then people weren't you weren't
pushing using the marketing wallet it it
this wasn't i mean if you're saying you
tried it you know you didn't like this
wasn't this wasn't a very hard try i've
been looking through your telegram the
telegram's been inactive you've been
inactive from the telegram is what i
mean it's not like the community has
seen you around seeing you trying and
they gave up they stopped you stopped
trying they stopped caring because you
stopped trying and then you withdrew all
the money while the people who are still
investing holding on are still believing
that like you're gonna come back and
basically save them with updates and
stuff like that
uh i mean why that's like seems really
messed up
i mean like i said the coin had so much
bad publicity that no influencers are
gonna work with it and it was
very stressful but it had bad publicity
because you were on the record saying
that you were gonna take everyone's
money and run then you said that wasn't
true
and then now you've taken everyone
everyone's money and run because you
said oh it had bad bad publicity but
that bad publicity was from you and then
you carried through on what you said
yeah i mean mistakes were made and i was
joking about that when i said that but
at this point like i said the coin isn't
active uh i don't want to work on it
anymore because it's just you know too
it's just too like it just wasn't
working out i don't know i don't know
what you mean by inactive though because
you are you are like the team that's
creating it if you stopped working on it
it's inactive but if you didn't stop
working on it then it's not inactive i
don't know what you mean
yeah cause i've been working on it for
months that's what i mean
you haven't been working on it
no
right so so your justification for
pulling all the money out is you stopped
working on it
so then that's what makes it okay for
you to take the money
well uh okay so i didn't want to work on
the coin anymore so the alternative is
to just
leave three hundred thousand dollars no
the alternative is tell the your
community you're not working on the coin
anymore it was a big mistake pull your
money out guys
i mean i thought that was
self-explanatory when i haven't been
active for months with it
you thought it was self-explanatory but
you didn't say it
so you really think that if you told
everyone hey guys this is a failed
project i'm not doing it anymore people
would have just left that money there
you literally think the money would have
just been burned
it would have gone to nobody
you don't think you could have tried to
get get people's money back
like i said there's forty two thousand
dollars in the liquidity still there's
not a lot of money involved three
hundred thousand i mean if we do the
math you took out almost ninety percent
of the liquidity so
you took out ninety percent of the money
right
um
why not try to give that back to your
fans who invested
they still have the ability to sell they
can get money they know there's forty
thousand dollars left to split between
all of them i'm saying you took out
three hundred thousand dollars why not
give that back to your fan to your fans
the people who invested in this
well you already invested you only
invested 50k you told me so
why not just give look you've already
been paid you've already been made whole
you didn't deliver on the platform you
didn't do what you said you were going
to do you said you got bored with the
platform
i guess fi like if if that's your thing
you just made a big mistake
give the money back you've been made
whole no one's hurt the way i see it
though you've taken 250k that really
doesn't belong to you
i mean i guess that's one way to put it
um i think of it the way to put it
sure okay um
i think you haven't done anything you
haven't you haven't created any value
you just made empty promises that you
didn't deliver on you said you got bored
and then you dipped out of the project
and said you thought it was
self-explanatory
i'll put it this way if i invest into a
coin
and it's not active for months
i'm gonna just sell
what i bought because why would i hold
money in there if it's not active for
months that's what i mean by
self-explanatory
so you think people just should have
known that they shouldn't at a certain
point they just shouldn't give you the
benefit of the doubt they should just
basically take their money and run
uh if
deadlines aren't met yeah that's base
that's like the responsibility of the
investor
so they were dumb to give you the
benefit of the doubt uh your your fans
were not smart to give you the benefit
of the doubt on this project that you
told them you're long term on
uh no that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying that if something's inactive
for months if you have money in there
that you don't want to lose
why are you like why keep it in there
it's inactive it's it's you know what i
mean
well dude i mean people are taking you
at your word they're taking you at what
you said you said um you know this is
long term right this is you in the
telegram this is thanks guys i assume
everyone here is in it for the long haul
to see this project come to life
yeah anyone who invests in this should
know it's a long-term project so one
week is not going to see results you're
the one saying people should not be
looking for short-term gains they should
be looking at it and like a long-term
project right
yeah
okay i said that i said that stuff when
i was working on it and
then it just wasn't working out so i
mean it didn't work out because you
stopped working on it paul
yeah i i
i told you the
it just the the
you're saying you stopped because you it
stopped working out but
no you stopped first and then you said
it was inactive then you took the money
and ran
uh
okay hold on no you that's not
you i mean sure the way you're putting
it is not false but you make it sound uh
like i had ill intentions from the
beginning which wasn't the case i tried
to use it no listen
there was a ton of glitches with it
there was people not donating using it
uh there was bad publicity so no
influencer was going to work with it no
matter how much money was in the
marketing wallet
and it
added a lot of stress into me uh you
know and
everyone's you know like uh i have a lot
of stuff on my shoulders with that and i
just didn't want to deal with distress i
didn't want to deal with it so
i stopped working on it
listen
all of that
maybe let's just say maybe we can
understand that you are a little too uh
ambitious you couldn't do it you're
saying i was in over my head
i i get that i get i was in over my head
i thought this would be an easy thing i
thought i was really excited about it
and then i wasn't
all of that i wouldn't have called you
i'm calling you because then after
deciding that you couldn't deliver you
gave up you decided to abandon people
then you took the money
that's what looks bad here
is that you took the money you're not
apparently you have no plans to give it
back which is just like blowing my mind
right now
okay
right you understand that you messed up
you failed and you're taking other
people's money who trusted you
that's why it looks bad that's why it's
a scam
i mean if that's what you want if that's
how you want to label it then sure i
mean how would you how would you label
it somebody makes a bunch of promises
they don't go through with it they don't
notify the community
and then they rug pool the liquidity 90
of the liquidity what would you call
that
uh i would call it pretty logical
logical
i mean i'll put it this way the stock
mark or not the stock market the crypto
market is crashing and
the 300 000 is in there there's two
options right leave the money in there
and then if bnb goes down it's like a
hundred dollars the money goes to [ __ ]
anyways or
i could take it and the money is not
just going to dust
money would have never gone to dust i
mean it just would go back to the
investors when they sold out when you
told them hey guys i'm no longer
interested in this project i wipe my
hands of it you know you got your 50k in
you got your 50k out you're good right
you didn't deliver this is not your
money i can't believe you keep thinking
of it as like as your money that's going
away that's your investor's money and it
should be their decision what they do
with it
okay i mean that's fair point
well that's not what happened
so that's what i'm saying when somebody
who's made a bunch of promises didn't
deliver misappropriates those funds
that's what we call a scam
you're pointing to these crypto markets
whatever
that's a scam so
i mean here's where it's at like
obviously
uh
you know this is
this is something i'm definitely gonna
cover
but i'd prefer it if there could be some
positive
into this where you actually return the
money to the investors so they can take
their money out that's my ideal goal
and i want to see if you here today can
just put that money back in i know you
have it you know you have it um put the
money back in the liquidity pool so that
people can sell
and take their money back
they can sell how much money do you
think is invested into the coin
what by who
by people who are holding it no no no no
no
here's the thing i'm saying you took out
300 000
why not put that money back in so people
can sell
because they can already still sell
there's only 40 i mean you rip the
liquidity pool apart
yeah but there's enough money in there
or people who have
any amounts of money to get out forty
thousand sure doesn't seem like a lot
but there's not a lot of money invested
into the coin so there's enough for
people to sell their portion that
doesn't even make sense
how does that all make sense okay okay
here's the thing
don't pretend like you don't understand
how liquidity pools work when you take
them out
okay then why are you acting obtuse like
you took out three hundred thousand
dollars if other people had withdrawn
all their money that three hundred
thousand dollars who wouldn't be there
would it
if even if what you're saying is let's
just say what you're saying is true
which is forty thousand dollars is
enough put your money back in they'll
all withdraw there will still be that
three hundred thousand dollars for you
if what you're saying is true and then
you can take it back out
how about you put it in there announce
to everybody that hey i gave up on this
project sell everything you can take
your money out and then whatever's left
if you're if what you're saying is true
and you know what people there everyone
can be made whole by this magical
accounting then you can have that 300
000 that uh was left over but you know
that's not true so that's why you're
hesitant to do it
well yeah i mean i don't want to do that
obviously
oh you want so you do you
so you want to keep the money that's not
yours that you took from the project
even though you'd failed to deliver
i mean i'm not really sure what you want
me to say but yeah
i mean i don't really like what you want
to say i just want you to admit it's a
scam
uh from the start i did not have ill
intentions but
you got ill intentions
okay hold on at this point
there are sometimes you come across
places in your life and you have to
scale something right
and sometimes you have to look out for
yourself
more than other people
wow
and you know that's one of these
situations and i mean i don't really
know how else to put it it's
if i i think of it like this
if somebody is still holding
money into a coin that's not active for
seven months six months however long
it's the responsibility they're like
part of the responsibility is on them as
well for being you know like putting too
much emotion into it
okay
you still didn't
answer my answer what i said which is
you said what do you want i said i want
you to admit this was a scam
just i i can tell you're having trouble
saying it because
you are at odds with what you did and
what you think of yourself but just tell
me just just be honest you scammed
people whether or not you meant to do it
now you have scammed people officially
and you refuse to give their money back
i'm it's i'm not going to say it was a
scam because that's just uh that wasn't
the intention from the beginning
but it eventually was the intention is
what i'm saying
my intention is to not [ __ ] people over
but like i said there comes certain
points
there comes certain points in your life
where you have to look out for yourself
and weigh the options right
and what did the option say and what did
the options say
uh the options say leave the money in
there
or take the some of the money like i
don't know like or tell or tell the
investors as the leader of this project
that you are no longer working on it
and take their money out while they
still can
i mean they still can
sure not everyone would be able to sell
but there's not a lot of money invested
into the coin i think more
i think some of the i think one of the
top wallet holders has like 4b
can you tell me how much money you made
off this um this what i'm i'll just call
it a scam i know you don't want to call
it a scam but it is a scam so what did
you make of this
well i got 55 and then 45 percent went
to uh my developers so
i probably i mean i'm trying to think i
don't know probably like 300 000
nice what what a good what a good profit
from doing um
i mean how long did you work on this
project
like seriously how long did you work i'm
just curious well like you said it was a
fork so a couple weeks
couple weeks three hundred thousand
dollars that's
that's a good uh it's a nice chunk of
change
what do you plan to do with the money
uh invest into crypto ethereum mainly
okay
cool well uh
all right i guess that's basically all
the questions i i don't i don't want to
run in circles about you i i can't
believe you won't just admit it was a
scam but
i think um that's basically all the
questions i had i'll be reporting on
this probably soon um
just
and uh i i don't know did you want to
say anything else
i mean there's not really much else to
say i've told you what
what my thought process is um
you know at the end at the end of the
day
there comes points where you have to
look out for yourself and i
think that
it's also some of the responsibility
falls on the people
that
are still for getting scammed yes i
agree
they should have known not to trust
influencer promises i agree with that
you and i agree on that
[Music]
yeah i don't trust influencer promises i
was more saying when something is an
inactive you sell that's bad no one knew
it was inactive right like dude i didn't
talk in the telegram i didn't do
anything with the coin for months right
i mean right
any logical person would know that the
project isn't active i've invested in
plenty of bsc coins and as soon as
something's not active anymore i sell
because that's you know the nature of
being constantly that it's a long-term
project you're working on on the uh
platform right people just assumed you
had got done what you should have been
doing which is coding working on the
project hiring developers working behind
the scenes projects do that all the time
where the team is you don't have to
constantly be in there but they're
constantly working on new updates
pushing new things right
you worked on it for a few weeks
told everyone it was a long-term project
told everyone you were working on it
made some half-assed attempt to get a
website up and then gave up waited to
your liquidity unlocked rugged the coin
while ghosting everybody and then now
you're just saying well gotta look out
for number one like you know get scammed
i guess like i guess that's the message
here
i mean would you prefer that i lied to
you or do you want me to no i want i
want you to no i'm happy you're telling
me the truth um you know uh but i think
it's messed up like i can be
grateful that you're honest while also
being like shocked and appalled that
like you're so brazen about this
you know like it's both things are true
well i mean this is terrible this is
terrible and it's also emblematic of a
wider attitude of influencers towards
their fans where they really don't care
about their fans and simultaneously
like are like fine with ripping people
off while also i think probably being i
don't know if you're aware of the fact
that your average fan has way less money
than you so you're just taking from poor
people like you understand that right
that is definitely not that that is not
a good way to put it that's a pretty
shitty way to put it my dude it's i
think it's a pretty shitty thing to do
sure i mean i can agree taking out
liquidity is
definitely not ethical but like i said
when there you know you sometimes you
have to look out for yourself and i
think by this point if somebody hasn't
used
logical reasoning to determine whether
or not they should sell
by this point
some of the responsibility also falls on
them
again again i what are you saying like i
i don't disagree with you that like
trusting influencers is always a mistake
right empty influencer promises right
like i i agree with you
that's a problem but if you're trying to
say they made a mistake so it makes the
shitty thing that i did okay like it's
like it's insane like that's crazy and
and
you're you just said like yeah like it's
like taking for poor people yeah
it is that's what that's literally what
it is your average viewer has way less
money than you and you took their money
and your only explanation is well they
were too dumb to realize how these
projects work so they deserve it i get i
don't know if you're trying to say they
deserve it you're saying they don't owe
some responsibility i agree with some
responsibility but do they deserve to
get ripped off
no i mean nobody deserves that
it's just not happen though
like i said sometimes you have to look
out for yourself uh i don't really know
how else you want me to put it i mean if
you i mean you could say it in all these
different ways to make it sound as
horrible as possible and you know what i
can agree with you on some of those
things i just don't like to put it in
those specific ways because it makes it
sound like that was the intention from
the start which it wasn't
uh but at this point the project's dead
there's three hundred thousand dollars
you know what i mean
might as well be yours right
i mean sure
yeah you took it um well i mean for you
i don't expect this will matter much you
can just lay low ride the 300 000 out
and you'll be fine um i i hope i could
say the same thing about whoever
put the money into this project
um
yeah it's like all the negatives we you
guys say all the negatives maybe say
some of the positives too when the coin
release there was scam coins or like you
know like coins that were uh had the
same name as my coin and people who
bought those i gave them money i
probably gave people i don't even know
maybe 30 40 000 my own money to people
who bought fake projects or if somebody
uh dm'd me and said they put like a
couple thousand in you know i gave them
like maybe
30 of it back like you know i was doing
things to try to help people out but at
a certain point you can't help people
out
so if you're going to say all the
negatives
when you have 300 000 you by definition
can still help people out right like
again i'm not telling you you have to
lose money on your project i'm saying
just give back everything else
and you're saying no you still want to
profit from a project you self-admit you
did
the minimum amount of work on got bored
gave up but you still want to basically
pocket the money and just say like yeah
well they it was their fault
for basically trusting me
anyways we're we're running in circles
um you're saying like i'm putting this
in bad ways uh i i think it's shitty so
i mean i'm just trying to recap i just
can't believe that nothing in this is
like sparking a response that makes you
feel bad that makes would make you want
to return this money um because it's
very much within your power to do so and
you and i both know that so i don't know
why you're acting like it has to end
with like you being the bad guy here
that's not what i'm trying to do at all
i'm trying to like get you to return the
money because it's 100 still available
and you could do that
so that's what i'm not understanding is
i want to get to that point i don't
think we're going to get there
um
so i don't know what there is to talk
about if you want the answer uh
yeah i could give the money back it is
within my power um
but i'm gonna look out for myself and
not do that i i you know i don't like
know what else to say that's just the
most honest answer do you think the uh
fbi should get involved with cases like
this or like the sec or do you think
like people like you should be
prosecuted
um
no
why not i mean i'm just saying crypto's
very unregulated right now uh but fraud
is still a crime i'm just asking you i'm
not saying you're guilty of anything i'm
not accusing you of that i'm just asking
what do you think should happen to
people who scam or take money or uh you
know take people's money from a project
that they didn't do much what do you
think should happen to them
um well i mean if they just rug pull
from the beginning then yeah that would
be really extra shitty and they should
probably
face some kind of repercussions
do you think like
like uh
civil or like criminal
well since it's unregulated i suppose
civil
so people have gone to jail for crypto i
mean that it's it still can be
prosecuted as fraud so it's it's
actually like more of the like the the
um like whether it's a security that's
not very well understood
um but you can still you can still
commit crimes with crypto obviously
everybody knows that um but
i guess
i guess what you're saying is that as
long as you wait like a few months
before you rug pull then you're good
i'm saying that i
gave it a try it was too stressful i
didn't want to do it it was getting too
much you know [ __ ] on it and uh you know
nobody was the platform was scuffed and
people weren't using it people were
finding glitches in it and i just didn't
want to deal with it and that's really
your last your last post in the in the
telegram was on the 30th of july when
did it launch
uh june
and when in june do you know
so you tried for like two months
or like
like a couple weeks
yeah you can see whether or not a
project's going to do well within a
couple weeks based on the attitude of
everyone
in the you know in the project
okay
so you had good intentions for a couple
weeks
okay i had good intentions for a while i
had personal stuff going on
shortly after that happened where i had
to take time off streaming and and then
i just didn't want to deal with the
stress of it i mean i don't really know
what you're
like wanting
me to say i don't know what you like
what do you want from me you know what i
mean like i'm telling you i want you to
return the money but i i think you're
just i think you're pretty determined on
that huh
determined on what i i said i want you
to return the money but i guess you're
pretty determined not to
i mean there's risk involved with with
everything right
well this isn't a matter of risk this is
just a matter of you making a decision
to do the right thing
right this is an ethical problem and i
agree and i agree that it's not a good
move uh in terms of ethics but
sometimes you have to look out for
yourself
okay all right i think that's all i can
uh would you rather be honest or would
you rather me sit here and [ __ ] you
and get nowhere i mean
i'd rather you return the money that's
my ideal second is i'd rather you be
honest and third yeah bullshitting's the
worst
so
we're i guess we're somewhere in the
middle here
but anyways i did i did at the beginning
help people get money back but like i
said at a certain point when it becomes
like at a certain point it you know some
of the responsibility is on them and i
did feel bad don't try to justify this
this is insane you can't try to justify
this you know it's wrong you're deciding
to do the unethical thing
i'm trying to code it don't try to code
it in some like i tried you didn't try
right you you decided to do the
unethical thing you're doubling down
don't try to code it in some like oh i
don't know it's like the responsibility
you are deciding to do the shitty thing
you know that and you're still doubling
down and that's where we're like we're
going to have to leave it
yeah
i am doubling down do you not do you not
agree though some of the responsibility
is on people who
if you're still holding something that's
inactive for months
like sure okay maybe they you know have
faith in me whatever but that's not a
good that's your fans dude that's your
fans these are people who followed you
since they were kids they admire you
they look up to you
that's the people you're saying well
that's their fault like loser gets
scammed okay first of all
the coin was a very niche part of my
community i didn't really advertise it
to my entire whole community i advertise
it to a niche part that understands
crypto again i can't i can't deal with
look i can deal with you being honest i
can't deal with like the like trying to
justify what you i prefer like the
honesty of like yeah i just you know
you're saying that i'm trying to scam my
entire fan base that's not true
uh there was i said your fans are the
buyers i didn't say your entire fan base
i said your fans are the ones who are
holding the coin so
it's the die hard fans of your community
and my fans and crypto people yes
well i yeah like i said that that's all
that's all really uh there is i guess um
thanks for being i i do appreciate you
being honest i do believe you're
extremely honest here um and i do
believe this is yeah one of the one of
the shittiest things i've seen in a
while
uh okay
all right that's it thanks man
all right bye later bye